[Music]
former drama teacher turned Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau has his
own illegal immigration crisis north of
the border border crossers are clogging
the asylum system in Canada and flooding
the homeless shelters so the Canadian
government has a new solution to all of
this move hundreds of immigrants into
hotels where they will live at public
expense Stephen LeDrew is a former
president of the Liberal Party of Canada
and he joins us tonight for an update on
all that singing thanks a lot for coming
on
so I chances are famously good-humoured
intolerant and sort of I would say a
little bit passive maybe but isn't even
saying anything well you're not you're
not passive that's and we're glad to
have you that I mean - I love Canada I'm
not attacking Canada but look what do
they think of come on come on up for a
holiday we'll give you a free hotel room
first of all the 800 Tucker are just
those who are now in in-school
classrooms and in school dormitories and
they have to be cleared out in order for
the classes to come back towards the end
of August so those 800 going to hotels
but that's always a thin edge of the
wedge on this one because last year we
had over 20,000 illegal asylum seekers
this year by the end of May I think we
had over 5,000 so there's thousands and
thousands and the mayor's particularly
John Tory the mayor of city Toronto are
saying we can no longer accommodate
anybody so the 800 million hotel rooms I
hope it's not the Four Seasons or the
Ritz but that is just a small number of
them so you asked about Canadians and
how they're responding these are very
generous we have an empty country up
here we could take a lot of people here
but on the other hand they don't like to
see their dollars being wasted so it
comes around to the fact that these
people seeking asylum tucker and you
know this they aren't coming into the
regular boarder places where they are
processed they are walking across and
the government of canada could stop that
with just just you know a signature on a
piece of paper they could stop that for
three months at least but they haven't
done that so Canadians are getting upset
about this on the other hand they're
also looking to the states and saying
well why are all these people in the
states and they're coming to Canada why
are they staying in the states they are
being kicked out of the states so that's
the question for you maybe it's because
okay well maybe because Canada
as more generous benefits in Killians
are even more calder and feel it yeah it
is it's much it's much colder so your
Prime Minister who I don't think really
gets the credit he deserves for being a
buffoon
no offense is basically telling
Canadians they're not allowed to
complain about this you're a bad person
if you're against this I think it's his
position he's saying that on a lot of
matters I mean they he's been seeing the
same tune since he's been in office
talking about you know you know gender
equality and all kinds of stuff he's had
a lot of failures over the last year and
people are starting to he's sorry to
wear thin so I don't think the Tories
where I'm gonna campaign we're gonna
have an election that Tucker in 14
months they haven't started saying yet
build the wall and make President Trump
a as he say with Mexico but it could
come down to something like that because
Trudeau is in fact saying not only on
pipelines I mean we paid one of your
Texas companies 4.5 billion with a beep
billion dollars that may not be that
much in the States and Canada is a lot
of mine we paid them a pipeline that
much for a pipeline out west because we
couldn't get them to agree with all the
terms of it and all kinds of other
protesters I mean he is a diamond I
meant to thank you for that by the way
Stephen we're out of time but I just
want to thank you
for injecting work in economy it's great
to see people 'true from Canada chatting
as always yeah